ariana grande Gina Rodriguez and more
celebs react to the London attacks
nearly two weeks after England's
Manchester bombing killed 22 and left a
hundred and sixteen injured London's
Metropolitan Police confirmed the city
was hit by two terrorist attacks one on
the London Bridge and another at the
Borough Market nearby on Saturday ariana
took to Twitter to share she's quote
praying for London while Gina Rodriguez
lamented I love you London this news
devastates me British actress and Grey's
Anatomy star Camilla Luddington tweeted
Manchester now London my family getting
alerts to check in on Facebook to let
others know you're safe I feel
physically sick the heartbreaking events
happened just one day before Ariana's
one luv Manchester benefit concert or
she'll be headlining the show along with
a star-studded lineup of friends and
fellow musicians Justin Bieber Miley
Cyrus Katy Perry and more are set to
perform
Ariana's manager Scooter Braun released
a statement on Instagram confirming the
concert will go on despite the attacks
in London writing we must not be afraid
and in tribute to all those affected
here and around the world we will bring
our voices together and sing loudly